[Music]
thank you so much for taking your time
for attending this session I will be
talking about how we automated the
medical coverage analysis using cloud
vision API and Google cloud machine
learning engine drew our editor uru
McCloud data engineer applause Evan we
are a Google cloud premier partner and
alongside with me on stage
I have Allyson and Joanne do you want to
quickly introduce yourself hi I'm in
research administration at the
University of Southern California
I am Joanne Peck and also at USC I do
coverage analysis very good without
further ado let me pull up today's
session outline after a brief
introduction of flora 7 and USC will
cover the Ulsan we'll be covering the
goals of research Enterprise followed by
Joanne
she'll be covering medical coverage
analysis workflow and then we'll tackle
the meat of the matter behind how we
automated the medical coverage analysis
at USC and then we'll open up for Q&A if
you have any specific questions feel
free to drop by after the talk and get
it clarified so through the 7vr a key
partner for implementation of artificial
intelligence and machine learning at
Google cloud we bring ai and ml
implementation to the customers who
either do not have the staff know how
the department or if they need any
extended hands we dive in as a team we
understand the use case what they are
trying to achieve and look at that data
to see if it's achievable and then we
work in tandem with the customers
throughout the journey of their machine
learning right from the project kickoff
to the production
and similarly we went to USC where we
demonstrated by providing a solution to
the UC showing them how we can leverage
machine learning and AI to automate
medical coverage analysis or to you
Allison thank you thank you Zhu vank Stu
Google cloud for inviting us so as you
probably know the University of Southern
California is a large private university
and academic Medical Center located in
Los Angeles California
we have strong research programs in many
clinical areas such as cancer biomedical
imaging neurosciences stem cells and
many more and collectively our
researchers conduct at least 20 sorry
200 clinical trials per year and those
clinical trials the goal of them are to
basically better understand diseases as
well as create new therapies and new
standards of care for patients so our
clinical and translational Sciences
Institute where I'm from is charged with
improving enhancing the research
pipeline to get more treatments to more
patients more quickly and given our
local population in LA we bring special
expertise and diverse populations
engaging diverse people in clinical
research and we bring that expertise to
our larger national network of
Institute's like ours and that's
important because when you test a
treatment just with one segment of the
population you don't know how well that
treatment will work for everybody else
so we aim to correct that by bringing in
more Los Angelenos into clinical
research and also trying to enhance the
research efficiency for all studies
so two years ago we surveyed researchers
at USC and many people complain about
different emergent administrative
processes burdens like too much
paperwork too many systems along
approval times and unclear requirements
and it's true in the we met we were able
to measure it and in the long lifecycle
of a single clinical trial from coming
up with the idea to publishing the
results there is a long pause in the
middle and it's not actual science
that's going on during this pause the
pauses for approvals and logistics there
are important things of course like
ethics committees to make sure that the
patients are you know undergoing
something that's safe they're setting up
pharmacy orders and they're negotiating
contracts and budgets with the
pharmaceutical companies or other
sponsors who are paying for the study
and so this activation process within
the red circles that takes about 10 to
20 people at least 80 hours per study to
complete with lots of back and forth and
long response times so even though it's
a team an hours it can take up to three
months on average and so that translates
into a delay in getting the treatments
to patients so we decided it's time to
change we embarked on a process
improvement initiative to make the
entire activation process faster and
more streamlined and more transparent
for the research teams at USC our scope
was studies that use hospital resources
where the study related costs had to be
distinguished and separated from the
regular clinical care costs and we
decided to take a lean process
improvement approach and to do that we
worked with a partner in the USC
Marshall School of Business who runs the
Center for supply chain management and
our thinking there was that if his
center could improve quality and speed
in manufacturing it could probably work
for research so we formed these working
groups and we got to work and this was
quite a culture shift because as you may
know speed is not exactly the number one
priority and academic administration but
the exercise of looking step by step and
everybody's individual processes
compared to all the other offices
involved in the whole activation process
that exercise of mapping the workflow
really helped us see the duplication
that exists and the redundancies it
helped us identify these bottlenecks and
the friction points which we termed
opportunities for improvement and then
we took a step back and we tried to
together create an ideal future State
workflow and started to implement those
improvements and this is too small to
read of course but this diagram should
just give you a sense of how complex the
research activation process is and
that's the future state diagram so fast
forward a couple years by last year we
had implemented almost over a quarter of
the steps which is a big reduction in
waste and duplication and it was just
small incremental improvements by
reducing a you know cutting out a step
here and there and introducing new new
processes and we have made the majority
of the changes in real life and the
outcome has been faster approvals for
studies so the average has dropped from
about 80 to around 60 days and we think
another outcome is a happier researcher
community so we surveyed the research
community again and they said the
process has become easier and less
frustrating but we know we have more to
do so in the spirit of continuous
improved
and we wanted to keep the momentum going
and we knew we had an opportunity to
really improve further with exponential
technologies so we turn to Google cloud
and machine learning and AI and with the
help of Pluto 7 we were able to see the
potential of using those technologies in
one piece of the process so using a
proof-of-concept project with Pluto 7 we
applied ml and AI to the part of the
budgeting process that's called Medicare
coverage analysis and I'll now turn it
over to our MCA expert at USC Joanne
Peck so MCA is medicare coverage
analysis and so basically this is our
workflow this is not just for USC but
it's usually what happens in other
academic sites so Medicare coverage
analysis basically what we do is we look
at the studies and look at the services
that we have to do tests and procedures
and determining will be covered by
Medicare so as it says Medicare coverage
analysis like is this going to be
covered by Medicare so in 2000 and the
2000 Clinton administration instituted a
clinical share policy basically what it
is is that if there are if it is a
qualified clinical trial certain items
and services can be built to the
insurance even though it's doing inside
of the clinical trial so with that and
all the research that we do we perform
Medicare coverage analysis and this is
just small part of the whole research
process that Allison was talking about
and this is a way of Pluto 7 and USD
partner to go over and perhaps that we
can bring machine learning and AI to
streamline and reduce the time they were
spending so the process is that protocol
we receive a protocol document meaning
that's the study document where
has studied design and objectives and
what we need to do while we are trying
to accomplish through this clinical
trial and who is going to do what and
what needs to be done so it's a PBL
usually PDF document we receive it and
as a coverage now analysts might like
myself we'll review the protocol and
protocol is are usually pretty thick and
there are a lot of scientific language
but what main thing that we look at is
what's called study calendar something
that looks like this this is just off
from a protocol study calendar scheduled
event we call it it shows on the left
side what things needs to be done at
what time point so this is just stuff
from a a protocol that's out there and
so we review the study calendar and
which is in PDF form and in order for us
to do coverage analysis at USC we use
something called encore it's a CTMS
clinical trial management system it's a
software we do everything in our core
however in many institutions that if
they're not using uncle or CTMS what
they choose to do it in Excel
spreadsheet so basically if we didn't
have our core what as a person what I
had to do is to get the media protocol
and look at this a page and then create
a basically copy and paste manually so
I'm typing everything on the left side
and then creating all the columns and
putting all the X's X's just mean it's
happening at this point
so that's the first step basically
creating an Excel version for all the
studies to be done at this point I'm not
doing any analysis I'm just copying it
and this is where Pluto 7 came in and
they were able to extract this
information into Excel spreadsheet by a
machine learning in AI and Dhruva is
gonna explain into details of our
technicality of that so once that's done
and on well we do first is we have to
find out if it's a qualified clinical
trial to see T stands for qualified
clinical trial so qualified clinical
trial they're setup questions that we
have to answer there are a few questions
answered but what's most important is
the three questions they all have to be
answered yes the first one is does this
recall IP IP stands in clinical trials
means the investigational product so for
if the drug is investigational product
brand new drug that their company is
developing is that fall into Medicare
benefit category Medicare benefit
category is just the list of services
that can be covered by Medicare not
clinical trial just by Medicare likes
for my mother who is on Medicare where
she goes to annual checkup that's
covered and when she needs an eye exam
that's not covered so it's like Medicare
benefit category so first we say does
this help in the medical medic Medicare
benefit category and if it is a drug
it's usually it drugs and biologicals so
I say yes and the next question is does
this study have a therapeutic intent
meaning is this study going to somehow
bring quality of life or extend your the
created some type of treatment they are
not just the collecting data not just to
see if doesn't have any toxicity so that
it doesn't have a therapeutic intent yes
and then next question is does this
accrue disease diagnose disease so
meaning the study had toward a like
breast cancer patient or a pulmonary
disease but so if it is yes those all
three questions have to be answered yes
and once it's answer yes that there's a
fourth question that has to be answered
that's themed trials so these are
usually if it is a study is funded by
government National Institute of Health
or Department of Department of Defense
or any government agency funding it it's
automatically deemed or does it have IND
investigational new drug application
filed to FDA so these are the type of
questions we go through and QC t
checklist and then once it says it's a
qualified trial it's a yes or no and the
qualifying trial just means that if
they're items and service is being done
in the trial even though it's doing only
for the study it can be built with them
Medicare if it is not qualify those
investigational items cannot be built
dangerous so for an example if I'm a
healthy if I'm a clinical trial I'm on
healthy subject and I'm on this clinical
trial for and if I'm not on a clinical
trial I'll just go to see my doctor once
a year that's can be built to Medicare
but if I'm a clinical trial and they
want to see me every month they want a
blood draw blood that's something that's
not going to be covered by Medicare on a
non qualified clinical trial so that's
what we went in that's that that
question drives next part and then what
the next part mean is that when we see
this one we have to determine one
example very top
informed consent that's something I look
at it but is this going to is this
consider research item or what we call
standard of
here informed consent just simply means
that patient is signing a consent form
that is I want to be in this clinical
trial so if the patient is not on a
clinical trial there's no reason for
them to sign informed consent so they'll
be research but usually then if you go
down let's say there is a there's a
complete physical exam physical exam is
being done as screening and then one
below is abbreviate the physical exam
that's being done at different time
points so at this different time points
research meaning something other than
insurance is going to pay for it as
standard care meaning it can be built to
the Medicare and insurance so like
extracting it for in this example we say
screening for the physical exam at
screening very first visit we say it's a
research but then you go down and then
determine that each one of them are by
the standard of care research so that's
the process of Medicare coverage
analysis and that analyzing each one of
them it's not just me just saying okay I
feel like saying it research I feel like
saying your standard of care but we do
go by the national coverage this
determination
there's a government on reference that
we have to follow or there's a National
Society guidelines for cancer trials so
we have something called NCCN guidelines
National Comprehensive Cancer Network
guidelines that tells us okay for these
patients in a breast cancer study to
have the image CT scans done every six
months is something routine so we use
that reference point to make that
determination so this whole process
takes from like basically somebody
sitting down reading the protocol
extracting it reading or finding all the
references and they're making into this
determination this is a very lengthy
process because it's not something that
if I don't do it right then USC can be
fine because it's something that even
though I midnight may be a mistake but
if I did not do the determination
correctly if I build something to the
Medicare incorrectly that's that the
Medicare would which should be the last
pair and then I'm saying that you are
the first pair so this is our manual
process that we go through and then
Dhruva is going to come and how the
total seven came in and streamlined what
part of this process in the swim lane
thank you right
thank you so much Joan and Alison so
this is how it works we have clinical
trials
protocols coming in the form of a PDF
they are stored in Google Cloud storage
Google Cloud Storage is and restful
online file system web service offered
by Google value can store and access
your data on GCP infrastructure and
followed by that we have App Engine here
App Engine is a service instance it's
fully managed by fully managed I mean
that the applications that are deployed
on the App Engine scales automatically
and you don't have to worry about the
underlying infrastructure all you have
to focus on is your code oh here App
Engine acts as a choreographer like a
Data Manager it follows the data into
the cloud vision API cloud vision API is
a pre-built machine learning model
offered by Google which can be accessed
through restful api it helps us to
enable and detect the text present in
the clinical trial protocols and
extracted and followed by that we have a
cloud machine learning engine where we
hosted our one D convolutional neural
network model it's a server less and
fully managed or you can also custom
select your resources that you would
like and it also offers training and
predicting services individually or
together I have kept the talk high level
but if you have any specific questions
regarding the technical details please
feel free to reach out to me before
going to the next slide by show of hands
how many of you here are data scientists
and data engineers very good it's pretty
good number
but we talked about the data set the
data says that we used here are from two
different sources one is USC registries
that the historical the clinical trial
protocols they had over the years and
followed by dark
we had publicly available datasets that
we got from clinical trials.gov it's
United States Library of Medicine they
are offering this
and it had clinical trial statements
extracted from 40,000 plus clinical
trial protocols I feel that this data
set is really good as it was written the
clinical trial terms and it's publicly
available in the URL mentioned here so
on your left you can see a snapshot of
one of the pages of the clinical trial
protocol which has the study objectives
primary objective secondary objectives
and so on we are passing the clinical
trial protocols in the form of a PDF
into cloud vision API which is a
preamble machine learning model that I
mentioned before it has multiple
features like label detection logo
detection face recognition handwriting
recognition but in this project we
leveraged optical character recognition
feature of cloud vision API where it
could detect and extract that takes out
of the PDS
and followed by that text pre-processing
is an integral part on an extremely
important step of machine learning
journey we spend significant amount of
time there because we've it the quality
of data and the amount of information
that you can extract out of the data is
extremely important and it determines
the ability of your quality of the model
and we spend significant amount of time
there in pre-processing as part of
pre-processing B we transform all the
statements that were extracted by cloud
vision API into sequence of words
separated by a white space and then we
also had to remove the punctuation x'
special characteristics characters like
non alphanumeric symbols like question
marks of the Greek science etc and then
once we pre-process the data we found
that the data was highly unbalanced the
data's are called unbalanced when when
when a class of data has a huge
dominance over the other
over here 70% of the statements that
were extracted were labeled as research
like join was mentioning research is
something that Medicare doesn't cover
where as standard is we had standard
statements to only 30 percentage of the
entire statements that were extracted
and to overcome that we used a random
unbalanced under sampling what does that
mean us we take the classes from the
minority classes and match it against
the majority so that they are equal and
use the rest of the classes during
validation followed by that we did
embedded training we used an approach I
mean used an open source library called
fast text it's used for text
representation
text classification and motivic
representation fast exist an extension
of vert of Veck it's a predictive model
that uses a rhotic stress input and it
predicts the word given its surrounding
in the context and YC versa over here
once we did the embedded training we
tested it out using a very rare word
which is gastroenteritis thanks to joy
and this is how we will work with the
customers to understand their data and
that's where their domain expertise
comes in it's a very rare data and as
you can see it could figure out the
corresponding embeddings for for that
particular word oh here it didn't even
appear in the training data but the
faster to fast it's embryo training
could figure out the word embeddings
whereas when we tried out other open
source libraries it throwed an error
since since that gastroenteritis word
wasn't present in their training cops by
the way if anyone is wondering what that
gastroenteritis is it's a type of a flu
I mean join has helped me to understand
what that is so it could faster text
word embedding could also figure out you
know it could generate better word
embeddings for Adwords
and also it could find word embeddings
for the words which are not even in the
part of you know the vocabulary and as a
part of next step we a text classifier
was trained using a deep neural networks
with the pre trained embeddings that we
built in the previous steps as inputs to
predict whether or not the short free
stay take statements that are extracted
using cloud vision API is a it's a
standard or that means whether it's
covered by a Medicare or it's covered by
research so the pre trained word
embeddings were used as input for
Wandy convolutional neural networks and
we hosted dot onto a Google cloud
machine learning engine so those three
points are the steps that we have taken
before deploying our GCM model onto GC
Emily which is converting all the
stainless sentences into data set in the
sequence of word indexes and we shuffled
the training and test data sets and also
prepare an embedding matrix which
contained an index I the embedding
vector for the word from the index I and
this is the overall model where where
the input text which is pre processed
and labeled as you know is taken and we
did an embedded training fast X which is
an extension of motivic and then we
train takes classifier using Bondi
convolutional neural network and we got
the predictions which is whether the
particular statement is a research or
standard so these are all the results
our model could predict whether that
statement is research or standard with
86 percentage of accuracy and the other
advantages of the model that we have
built is its quick to Train on GPU so
within ten to fifteen minutes we were
able to train our model and then we
could you know we could try out multiple
architectures then a short amount of
time and the other one is you CPU at
inference time once your model is up and
running you know you don't need a GPU
you can do it on CPU which is lower cost
compared to TP and third point is you
can train periodically if required
consider if a new set of protocols comes
into their registry and the guidelines
keep changing its new drugs coming so
you can keep your model updated by
retraining it periodically
sir and rights I'll pass it on to
Allison in terms of closing from usc's
perspective we really felt like this was
a successful proof-of-concept project so
the concept has been proven compared to
a human only determination process this
technology really showed that it could
drastically reduce the time needed for
this part of the processing so we hope
that we can extend the solution beyond
breast cancer and two other pieces of
the whole puzzle and really make an
impact in the speed of research
activation and other areas of the
research lifecycle thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]